jetzt freuen die sich wie ein schaf es
heißt tun
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge von minecraft fact was jetzt immer
dienstags hochgeladen wird habe ich in
der letzten folge schon gesagt immer
dienstags bekommt ihr eine neue folge
und glücklicherweise beziehungsweise
komischerweise beziehungsweise irgendwie
interessanter weise passt es genau das
am 24
also an weihnachten ist genau am
dienstag das heißt da kommt dann auch
eine facts folge wollt ihr dass ich da
10 facts vorstelle wenn ja dann gebt
einfach mal daumen hoch wenn ihr das
nicht wollt einen treffer am daumen
runter da mache ich noch x wie x 46 also
36 plus von fact und wenn ihr es wollt
dann könnt ihr mir ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele effekte die kommentare schreiben
und per mail an kontraste gmail.com
allerdings nur funktionieren weil alles
andere werde ich einfach löschen
blockieren keine ahnung weil es bringt
nichts wenn man die kacke darunter
schreibt und ich investiere in meiner
zeit daran dass irgendwie zu probieren
komplizierte redstone schaltung und das
kombi und das funktioniert dann einfach
nicht so block blöcke irgendwie
duplizieren oder irgendwo bugs oder
ihnen gesetzt und es geht dann einfach
nicht weil das verschwendete zeiten das
einfach nur blöd wenn man sowas unter
video schreibt apropos unter video
schreiben es gibt zwei sachen die ich
euch noch sagen wollte bevor es losgeht
und zwar die erste sache in letzter zeit
werden wird verläuft untermain
effektives geschrieben dass die facts
auch alle von sparks tollen videos
geklaut sein stark macht jetzt irgendwie
auch eine fake serie mit so wurde er so
sachen vorstellt die minecraft noch
nicht kennt also quasi halt wie meine
minecraft weg und stellte ihm die
gleichen sachen vor wie ich und ich weiß
nicht also ich stelle immer kommentare
vor die locker schon ein zwei monate her
sind unter alten folgen auch immer weil
ich die dann auch im angucke und die
stelle ich halt dann vor und die hat er
dann irgendwie auch schon vorgestellt
oder stellt die irgendwie auch nach mir
vor mir wieder vorgeworfen würde was
neuen wie von von spark geklaut erwägen
doch wenigstens das ist richtig armselig
also ich hatte die serie zuerst das war
zuerst mal eine idee ich nehme nur euro
kommentar ich wusste ich dass er so eine
serie macht bis vor kurzem ich hab' ich
schwöre auf mein leben ich habe keine
fakes irgendwie aus einem video genommen
weil sowas wenn ich auch kaffee wächst
doppelt vorgestellt werden
ich gucke das nicht ich hab's park nicht
abonniert ich gucke diese serie nicht
und es tut mir leid wenn da ihnen die
sachen doppelt vorgestellt werden ich
meinen könnte theoretisch einfach
überspringen oder ihr schaut halt nur
auf einem kanal nur ich kann nur sagen
ich hab mit der serie angefangen und es
ist nicht schlimm dass er auch so was
macht aber wenn man sich dann halt als
zuschauer aber beschwert sich dass schon
ein bisschen doof ich weiß nicht ob er
jetzt auch kann ja sein dass er auch
kommentare von unter meinen videos da
liest irgendwie darüber aber ich möchte
kein was unterstellen nur dass ihr das
einfach wisst dass ich da nicht
irgendwie von nehme und das natürlich
gleiche sachen da irgendwie vorkommen
können weil in minecraft gibt es noch
nie so viel effekt sich auch daran wie
hoch die beteiligung hier ist da werden
immer sehr viel effekt zwar geschrieben
aber sehr wenig richtige und naja die
zweite sache die ich noch eben kurz
sagen wollte ein großes dankeschön an
theresa die mir gestern habe ich so wie
geschrieben die hat mir vorgestern
richtig viele mails bezüglich der
auflösung these also bezogen auf das
marxistische klasse modell oder bezogen
auf die individuell individualisierungs
theorie oder die sozialen sicherung zwei
in deutschland und so was alles also
wirtschafts schwachsinn weitergeholfen
dann kann dich theresa die sowie klausur
waren richtig gut
dann würde ich sagen fangen wir jetzt
auch schon mit dem ersten effekte an und
zwar geht es hier um die haltbarkeit
beziehungsweise nutzbarkeit von
werkzeugen und zwar ich setze erstmal
ganz kurz baumann sondern sogar kc heros
ein schöner baum geworden hab ich mich
jetzt mal ganz kurz hoch ihr seht schon
ich hab ein paar wurden werkzeuge bei
mir drin wurden werkzeuge guttenberg
zurück und ja das war's
und zwar wenn ich theoretisch jetzt mit
seiner axt er hier das abbauen da seht
ihr unten schon die axt nutzt sich ab
wenn ich das mit einer pigs abbauen
seine spitzhacke nutze ich das auch ab
mit einer schaufel selbstverständlich
auch allerdings mit einer hoch
nutze ich die hohen nicht ab das heißt
in den neubau dabei hat baut damit immer
blätter ab und es kommt trotzdem
setzlinge raus und äpfel etc
wenn irgendwie blätter abbauen wollte
oder setzlinge braucht oder irgendwie
auf
ihr sucht apple hofft dass zuerst aber
wollte werkzeug nicht kaputt machen
könnte davon nach oben
ich denke dass wussten sehr sehr wenige
von euch das ist dann fekter dass man
auch so was vor allem hat die person
erst nur mit einer spitze mit einer
hacke gibt es keinen keinen nutzbarkeit
abzugs dingsbums allerdings war es halt
dann so dass ich dann esse ich hatte
erst hatte als juden packs was man ja
normalerweise macht definiert dann
vorhin schon einmal aufgenommen das gab
die dritte aufnahme möchtest dann noch
mal falsch bezogen habe auch etwas
anderes
und jetzt ist es doch die wurden hoch
gewesen und ja also da wenn ihr das mit
der boden hohe abbaut dann die nicht
runter von der haltbarkeit quasi und lag
in 2
jetzt nicht in meiner effects welt auf
sondern einfach mal auf dem mount blade
server was ich findest du damit der
beste server den es gibt für pvp et
cetera die haben jetzt übrigens auch
survival games also der server gehört
mir nicht ich krieg da keine
finanziellen mitteln hier irgendwie
dafür dass sie irgendwie menschen in
meinen videos aber ich finds halt
einfach geil und ich möchte die leute so
ein bisschen von hf weg locken weil es
einfach eine kommerzielle kacke das ist
ja egal
kommen wir zum effekt und zwar ist der
effektivzins aber komisch ist erfährt
ganz einfach jetzt so oft gefragt hey
luca wie machst du das du einen
buchstaben entsteht ein gefühl dann
direkt weiß welche spieler es ist also
einfach das hier zum beispiel firefox
doppel frederico 10 zum beispiel
frederico 10 kann jetzt einfach
schreiben frederick lau im auge hatten
cool skin hätten richtig coolen scannen
das ist cool nein das mache ich ganz
einfach indem ich irgend ein buchstabe
angeblich wie zb einfach rein und jetzt
drückt man space ist kann einer drückt
man tab also diese tasten mit dem einen
fall gegen davis cup hck ich jetzt so
machen chris gibt es konkreter gibt es
krieg gibt es chris kong kreft der kripo
hin und her switchen
wenn jetzt irgendwie den darauf wer
könnte ich die eingeben drückt antep und
dann kommt lena oder davor kommt alibi
darius dann kommt einer und dann kann
ich den er schreiben dass es in den
zwei aufnahmen immer ganz ehrlich wenn
man mit ihm im team machen will dann
muss ich schreiben philipp 122 ich weiß
gar nicht über namen schreibt oder sogar
conny geschrieben so viel weil dann
durch jan-philipp ich nehme gerade
effects wagen auf du bist jetzt live
dabei jetzt freuen die sich wie ein
schaf es heißt du so stellt euch vor
also ich bin jetzt erstmal wieder
minecraft facts welt stellen wir sind
wieder zu hause bin ich dadurch vor ich
weiß gerade einen heftigen kampf wir
sehen hier noch ein paar pfeile die
gerade im wie dies bei uns sind aber ja
ich bin auf jeden fall total am ende
jemand sie doch aus ich wurde richtig
ich mich richtig tot gemacht fasst
allerdings habe ich alles gelte besiegt
und eure rüstung ist es halt so ein
bisschen kaputt und ihr wollt jetzt
reparieren ich habe 25 level und zwar
kann ich jetzt einfach zu einem amboss
gehen erstmal natürlich meine rüstung
ausziehen so rüstung des ausgezogen kann
er zu einem amboss gehen kann da ein
teil reinpacken
ein eisen und dann kann ich meine
rüstung reparieren also meine chain
rüstung also diese eisen rüstung und
zwar muss ich dafür immer ein eisen da
rein tun und das kostet auch nur ein
level das ist richtig richtig gut und
dann kann ich einfach zu reparieren also
ich glaube es kommt auf die dings an auf
die wie viel das kaputt ist meinerseits
ein bisschen kaputt aber es hat nur ein
level gekostet und es ist auf jeden fall
besser als die ganze rüstung neu zu
machen einfach dazu ein bisschen
erfahrung auszugeben weil es kostet
wirklich das teil plus ein eisen und
sonst an helm oder so einen brustpanzer
kostet etwa acht reisen und im
singleplayer kann also schon mal selten
vorkommen denn man nicht irgendwie hex
spielt oder ähnliches und das perfekt
zwei okay ich bin doch das perfekte so
kommen wir zum 4 effekt und zwar auch
wann fällt wir sind schon wieder in
einer anderen welt also diesmal recht zu
der welt en suite die welten switch
folge und zwar als politischen die ganze
zeit so ein paar
münchen auf einem block und zwar wenn
ich diesen blog weg schlag und einmal
die mission schlager haben wir ein lüner
regen und das wollte ich einfach mal
zeigen
das sieht sehr sehr witzig aus den
ganzen wiener sind ineinander und die da
kann schon sehr heftig und die freuen
sich einfach darauf dass ich dir gleich
zerschlage und da haben wir unseren
hühner legen ja ja
junge regeln wo man gottes sieht echt
heftig aus sehr viele hühner
ich habe sie erst mal zum beispiel
screenshots gemacht also man kann es
natürlich noch deutlich deutlich länger
machen
aber jetzt haben wir einen hänger regen
von hier oben sieht das gar nicht so
viel aus aber wenn man unten ist
stell dir vor es gibt eine welt wo
einfach so richtig richtig viele mob
sind es war richtig krank
ich will jetzt ratet mal warum ich das
nicht meine welt gemacht hab ich habe
das meiner facts welt geprobt
funktioniert hier schön wie in proben
wie james ex topmodel jedes bescheid
jeden abend eine weintraube essen es
reicht ich glaube ich wetter koch
einfach das mega gut ich hab ich auf
jeden fall von meinen kochs game ein
apfel ins hoch kommt oder zwei äpfel
aber dass dann auch noch an weihnachten
mehr da war halt alles voll mit schicken
und das mit aufräumen und bla bla bla
bla bla
na ja meine lieben freunde ich würde
sagen das wars mit der heutigen facts
folge ihr könnt ihr wieder ganz ganz
fleißig fix in die kommentare schreiben
eventuell auch sachen die eventuell noch
keiner weiß und die auch funktionieren
das sind die besten sachen irgendwie
sowas wie also das sind jetzt nicht aber
so dass wir ja wenn man einen will und
über einen sand block setzen geht der
sandrock in den entweder man ist es wird
ein schalter gedroppt irgendwie sowas so
was so crazy sachen halt die noch keiner
weise nicht irgendwie sowas wie auch
wenn man mit links blinken block steht
dann geht aber kaputt nicht irgendwie
sowas und das könnt ihr jetzt einfach in
die kommentare schreiben
und dann würde ich sagen wenn es euch
gefallen habe ich mich definitiv bei der
bewertung freunde egal ob positiv oder
negativ wie ich als video halt gefallen
hat und dann will ich sagen sie uns bei
mir ist mal wieder reinschauen